Trascrizione: GIULIA DELLAMORTE
Revisore: Michele Gianella
"Per quanto tu cammini,
per quante strade tu possa percorrere,
non troverai mai i confini dell'anima,
così profonda è la sua vera essenza. "
Queste parole ci riportano
molto indietro nel tempo;
si tratta infatti
del frammento di un'opera
di un filosofo greco, Eraclito,
vissuto nel VI secolo avanti Cristo.
Ma allo stesso Eraclito dobbiamo, anche,
un'altra fulminante sentenza,
quella che dice:
"Il Sole non oltrepasserà i confini,
altrimenti le Furie,
che sono ministre della Giustizia,
lo afferrano e lo riporteranno
dentro i confini".
Eraclito era soprannominato,
dai suoi contemporanei "l'oscuro",
perché si riteneva che parlasse
in maniera incomprensibile.
Ma se riflettiamo insieme,
in margine ai due frammenti che ho letto,
possiamo certamente stabilire
che ciò che Eraclito intende dire
è tutt'altro che oscuro;
anzi, è di cristallina chiarezza.
Che cosa vogliono dire,
i due frammenti che ho letto?
Essenzialmente,
sottolineano due aspetti importanti
relativi al concetto di confine:
anzitutto, che i confini ci sono.
Esistono i confini,
anche indipendentemente dal fatto
che riusciamo effettivamente
a raggiungerli.
Può accadere che non riusciamo a trovarli;
e tuttavia, i confini ci sono.
E dovremmo tentare di uniformare
il nostro comportamento
alla consapevolezza
dell'esistenza di confini.
E poi, i due frammenti di Eraclito
ci dicono un'altra cosa importante:
ci dicono che non si devono
superare i confini,
perché oltrepassare il confine
è fare ingiustizia,
è macchiarsi di una colpa
che presto o tardi sarà sanzionata.
Tenete presente
che in tutto il mondo greco
arcaico e classico
la colpa fondamentale si chiamava hybris,
e la hybris è proprio il tentativo
di andare al di là
dei confini che sono fissati.
Insomma, spero che sarete d'accordo
nel ritenere che Eraclito
non era affatto un filosofo oscuro,
né che dicesse delle cose incomprensibili:
anzi, ci ha aiutato a impostare
la nostra riflessione
sul concetto di confine.
Ma si tratta, anche,
di andare oltre le sentenze
di un filosofo antico
per andare davvero a fondo
del concetto di confine.
E allora, oltre a tutte le cose
che sono state già dette,
in maniera ammirevole,
dagli altri speaker,
io vorrei attirare la vostra attenzione
soprattutto su due caratteristiche
peculiari della nozione di confine;
caratteristiche che non sempre vengono
individuate e riconosciute come tali.
La prima: il confine è capace
di convertire la quantità in qualità.
Provate a pensarci: il tracciare il solco.
Il formulare il confine,
attiva, istituisce, alcune polarità
che sono fondamentali
dal punto di vista qualitativo:
la polarità interno/esterno,
dentro/fuori, familiare/estraneo,
dritto/storto, giusto/erroneo.
Da questo punto di vista,
noi potremmo dire
che il confine conferma
quello che un grande
pensatore del Novecento,
uno dei massimi, dei giganti
del pensiero filosofico contemporaneo,
aveva osservato a proposito
della qualità degli spazi.
L'autore a cui mi riferisco
è Michel Foucault,
il quale parte da una
constatazione elementare,
con la quale possiamo
certamente convenire:
cioè che abitualmente si pensa
che le differenze
che intervengono nello spazio
possano essere solo
differenze quantitative.
Una porzione di spazio
è più grande o più piccola,
più lunga o più larga;
e cioè, noi siamo pronti a riconoscere
elementi geometrici
descrittivi dello spazio.
Ma quello che non sempre riconosciamo
è che lo spazio, o gli spazi,
hanno una loro specifica qualità,
che talora è difficile da riconoscere.
È la qualità che, ad esempio,
vediamo funzionare
quando ci riferiamo ad una
esemplificazione limpida, trasparente:
cioè l'origine del tempio.
Voi sapete che il tempio,
come luogo di accoglienza del divino,
ha una storia antichissima.
Ebbene, prima ancora che i templi
fossero costruzioni,
era sufficiente tracciare un solco
con una forma circolare,
o una forma rettangolare,
per trasformare la qualità
dello spazio circoscritto dal solco.
Quello spazio diventava
lo spazio del sacro,
lo spazio qualitativamente diverso
dal resto dello spazio,
anche se apparentemente
non si registrava alcuna differenza.
Ma vi è, e con questa
mi avvio a concludere,
una seconda peculiarità
della nozione di confine
che mi permetto di raccomandare
alla vostra attenzione.
È stato detto anche
da questo palco, questa sera,
che il confine è la linea che separa,
che istituisce uno scarto,
che include ed esclude.
Ma ciò che è davvero
più caratteristico del confine
è il cum.
È il fatto che quel finis,
quella linea che circoscrive
e traccia il solco,
è un luogo di incontro.
È un luogo di rapporto:
nello spazio qualitativo del confine,
di quel confine che è cum
io incontro l'altro,
ed è lì che allora
va in gioco la mia identità,
che posso cercare di definire
solo in rapporto all'alterità dell'Altro.
Come definire la mia identità,
se non nel rapporto con l'altro?
Da questo punto di vista,
il confine è appunto
il luogo di un incontro
nel quale conquisto la mia identità
nel rapporto con l'altro.
Sì, nel rapporto con l'altro:
ma a condizione che io, quell'altro,
sia disposto a riconoscerlo
nella sua radicale alterità rispetto a me,
che non lo consideri tale
da poter essere accettato
solo se mi assomiglia.
Perché allora perderebbe la sua alterità,
e farebbe smarrire a me l'identità
che nasce dal rapporto con l'altro.
E sul confine,
concetto in cui è fondamentale,
come dicevo, il cum,
e che lo differenzia da altri concetti
apparentemente simili,
come ad esempio "frontiera";
mentre nella frontiera
io mi trovo in una condizione
nella quale affronto l'altro,
e presto o tardi questo affrontarsi,
questo confrontarsi,
è probabile che degeneri a scontro,
nel confine prevale il cum,
e nel confine incontro lo straniero,
quel radicalmente altro da me
che mi fa dono della mia identità.
E che io devo accogliere,
anche se non so, non posso sapere
all'incontro con l'altro,
se è hospes, cioè ospite amico,
o hostis, cioè nemico.
Non posso saperlo,
ma devo ugualmente accoglierlo.
E non per generosità,
ma perché devo costruire la mia identità
solo nel rapporto con l'altro.
Insomma, come vedete questi concetti
ci fanno ritornare alla mente
la sentenza di Eraclito:
"Per quanto tu cammini,
e per quante strade tu possa percorrere,
non troverai mai i confini dell'anima,
così profonda è la sua vera essenza".
Grazie.
(Applausi)